this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer on November 3rd
1973 the Mariner 10 probe set sail for
Venus where it gave us our first
close-up look of the planet all the
while lending its gravity to boost the
probes velocity to its next destination
mercury this mission gave humankind many
of its first experiences with space
travel it was the first time a gravity
assist had ever been performed using a
planet's gravity it was the first time
two planets had been visited up close in
a single mission and it was the first
time solar pressure had been used to
control a spacecrafts attitude but that
wasn't by design this mission came
incredibly close to being a complete
failure as a result of debris floating
around the spacecraft interfering with
the start tracking navigation camera
each time it happened Mariner 10 needed
to perform a corrective role to
reacquire a lock-on Canova's its
reference star to make matters worse
this occurred more frequently as the
brightness of the particles increased as
Mariner 10 approached the Sun Mariner 10
managed to complete its gravitational
slingshot by Venus and was now limping
on to mercury but was quickly running
out of nitrogen the propellant needed to
perform these maneuvers to solve this
problem the engineers came up with a
genius plan by tilting the solar panels
they could use solar pressure the force
exerted by photons to control its roll
and stabilize its position a huge moment
that proved the viability of solar sails
for future use in spacecraft and just
this year light sail 2 provided a
valuable technology demonstration of
solar sails ability to provide control
at very low cost for small satellites
Before we jump into what light sail 2
achieved let's first see how it works
although photons don't have mass they do
have momentum which can be transferred
into an object with a reflective surface
this is a bit counterintuitive for
anyone that has learned like me that
momentum equals mass by velocity so we
need a new equation to describe
momentum of a photon and here it is the
momentum of a single photon can be found
by dividing Planck's constant by the
wavelength of the photon
since Planck's constant is well a
constant the momentum of a photon is
entirely determined by the wavelength
with shorter waves having higher
momentum finding the momentum of a
wavelength of 500 nanometers we can find
a momentum of just 1.3 by 10 to the
minus 27 kilogram meters per second
that's obviously tiny but when dealing
with the vacuum of space that can add up
when every single collision of a photon
with the solar sails provides an
increase in velocity of the spacecraft
thanks to our friendly neighborhood laws
of physics or the conservation of
momentum to be exact which states that
the change in momentum of a photon must
involve an equal and opposite change in
momentum for the object it interacted
with we can maximize this transfer of
momentum by ensuring the sale is as
close to a perfect mirror as possible
wasting as little energy as possible to
the heating of the sails but this isn't
the only factor that varies the force a
light source can in Paris on a solar
sail a less friendly neighborhood law of
physics the inverse square law states
that the intensity of a point source of
energy say the Sun will decrease with
the square of the distance away from it
this is a result of the energy spreading
over a greater distance as it radiates
outwards this basically just means less
photons will hit the sail the further
away it is from the Sun so if a solar
sail was double the distance from the
Sun it would only receive a quarter of
the photons triple the distance and the
sail would receive 1/9
this makes the solar sail increasingly
ineffective as we traveled to the outer
edges of the solar system and beyond the
other primary factor that affects the
force imparted on the sail is the angle
at which the photons strike the sail you
can think of this like a game of pool
where the angle the Q ball strikes
another ball will determine the
direction it travels in or you can
dispense with the useless analogies and
think of it as a photon bouncing off
mirror the direction of thrust will
always be perpendicular to the mirror
and vary with the cosine of the angle of
incidence when the sail is perpendicular
to the incoming photons the incidence
angle will be zero and the cosine of
zero is one and thus it will be at a
maximum of course the effective area of
the sail also decreases as it angles
away from the Sun the effective area can
be found by multiplying the total area
by the cosine of the incidence angle and
thus the force really varies with the
cosine squared of the incidence angle
putting all this theory to work we can
see how the light sail to achieved its
goals light sail to was a project by the
Planetary Society a company formed by
Carl Sagan Bruce Murray and Louis
Friedman back in 1980 with a goal of
raising funds for exciting missions
through crowdfunding it is currently run
by my buddy Bill Nye as you can see here
he totally knew who I was and didn't
think I was just a fun nervously asking
him for a photo light sail to is a tiny
craft weighing just five kilograms an
eleven point three centimeters in width
and 34 centimeters long but when
deployed the sails had an area of 32
metres squared this compact size allowed
it to ride share on a falcon heavy
mission in June 2019 launching into
orbit around Earth at 720 kilometers
when light sail too is moving away from
the Sun it faces it sails towards the
Sun to maximize the acceleration then as
it moves back towards the Sun it turns
on its side so the solar sail isn't
slowed down but as the earth blocks the
Sun for about half of its orbit we are
only really getting thrust for about one
quarter of its orbital period this
constant adjustment of orientation will
make a solar sail in planetary orbit
heavily dependent on reliable control
moment gyros and as the sail grows an
area the more demanding this requirement
will be both on the size of the
equipment needed and the energy required
but the technology does exist by
performing this maneuver every period
light sail to managed to raise its
Apogee by 2
in its first week of solar sailing
however the lowest point of its orbit or
its perigee has been decreasing at a
faster rate meaning the orbital energy
of light sail - is actually decreasing
this is happening primarily because the
spacecraft still comes into contact with
Earth's atmosphere even at 720
kilometers since the solar sail by
design has a large surface area with
very little mass the small traces of
atmosphere found at 720 kilometers are
enough to significantly slow down the
spacecraft's velocity this drop in
velocity causes the spacecraft to dip
further into the atmosphere where the
drag increases slowing the spacecraft
down even more because of this light
sail - is expected to deorbit in about a
year this could have been mostly avoided
if the spacecraft was placed into a
higher orbit where it would experience
more solar pressure and less atmospheric
drag the point at which these two
pressures equals is around 800 to 1,000
kilometers above Earth's surface so any
useful solar sail would need to be
launched higher than this nevertheless
the increasing apogee of light sail -
has proven that solar sailing could be a
useful technology for future space
missions but I'm not sure why we needed
to prove that since Mariner 10 did that
40 years ago is in the least provided
additional data and design verification
for future solar sails so beyond this
not so ideal application how could we
potentially use solar sails to develop
new technologies perhaps one of the most
important could be an early warning
system for solar flares to do this we
would need a spacecraft to keep a
position directly between the Earth and
the Sun anyone familiar with Kepler's
laws of orbital mechanics will know this
is difficult as any object orbiting
closer to the Sun will have a higher
velocity and a shorter orbital period so
it would be racing ahead of Earth to
maintain this position a spacecraft
would need to constantly push back into
position and obviously propellant would
pretty quickly run out so solar sails
are the perfect solution for this and
they will be able to achieve
more thrust the closer they get to the
Sun we already have several satellites
for this purpose Parkton Lagrange point
one which is the point at which the
gravity exerted by Earth and the gravity
exerted by the Sun is the same however a
solar sail with a 67 by 67 meter area
would allow a satellite to double its
distance from Earth and thus provide
double the warning time at about two
hours this would provide earth vital
time to prepare for a solar storm and
protect our satellite in orbit and our
grid system larger sails would allow the
satellite to park even closer to the Sun
but we begin to run into engineering
challenges as we approach the Sun with
unpacking the larger sail and protecting
it from the sun's heat if we had
suitable materials that could be both
extremely thin reflective light and heat
resistant we could sail even closer to
the Sun to perform Sun diving maneuvers
to capture the sun's energy to increase
our velocity and explore the outer solar
system there are countless other
applications for this technology that
you can learn about with the reference
material in the description but you may
have difficulty understanding them
without a decent understanding of
orbital mechanics I started to read up
on this subject myself in anticipation
for the new Kepler space program game
and brilliance course on gravitational
physics will teach you everything you
need to know about Kepler's laws of
orbital mechanics and much more or you
could complete one of brilliants daily
challenges each day brilliant presents
you with interesting scientific and
mathematical problems to test your brain
each daily challenge provides you with
the context and framework that you need
to tackle it so that you can learn the
concepts by applying them if you like
the problem and want to learn more there
is a course quiz that explores the same
concept in greater detail if you are
confused and need more guidance there's
a community of thousands of learners
discussing the problems and writing
solutions daily challenges are
thought-provoking challenges that will
lead you from curiosity to mastery one
day at a time
if I've inspired you and you want to
educate yourself then go to brilliant
org for it slash real engineering and
sign up for free and the first five
people that go to that link will get 20%
off the annual premium subscription so
you can get full access to all their
courses as well as the entire daily
challenges archive as always thanks for
watching and thank you to all my patreon
supporters if you'd like to see more
from me the links to my Instagram
Twitter subreddit and discord server are
below